for
calculi
going on
or or
to me and you were able to do
pleasures in life i'd want it i'd love
to you don't like to fix beginners for
my friends and have a good time p
you don't have to be things that are bad
for you in order to have exited
succulent and tasty and wonderful
if you haven't uh... tasted a lot of
things in their natural state
being run right out and do it because
it's great i mean it's really fantastic
and it's efficient so many people miss
out on that because the so-called
convenience foods
because i get up which should go i guess
change considerably in the past
twenty five years
until nineteen fifty we had essentially
in agriculture and food supply that is a
situation where
who has grown by the farmer taken to the
uh...
boats
unchanged by the housewife
and cook and bake this for a family
since nineteen fifty and increasingly
since nineteen sixty
that we have given up
they all week
bush come to us
and industrial food supplies that is one
where foods were more and more processed
anywhere and stayed out of the food
uh... has grown being sold
the food was in a sense my
an entirely new
made from it
food itself
is not a new idea
new methods and processes
are changing our reading habits with
factory food wheels and number two okay
many of the modern
so-called modern
are not nearly as nutritious as the old
fashioned
fruits and vegetables and other products
we got from
any of these
foods are high in sugar
clients office
the number of cases nutrients have been
removed from
when he had this up the nutritional
of the american diet
has actually deteriorated in recent
years things are getting worse
today so we can buy good for them
our diets are worse than they were ten
years ago
too many of us have health problems
because we need for me
too many non nutritious foods
too few vitamins and minerals
this bad but i'm making right now is
made
with whole wheat flour
which is just elf
stone ground and honey and milk and
synthetic meecham
so if you know they will be a good but i
mean you will not only taste really
delicious but they were ruby
a really useful and good
white bread they combined store white
leading maker so far we find in a white
flowers have that we can we moved in
branding moved
is
almost entirely starch
as food is processed
nutrients are usually removed
knowing of green is a glaring example
most of the minerals and vitamins and
all week colonel are on the surface
from the brannon outer layers
and in the growing center calm creature
flour made from the complete week
colonel
all week long
contains these nutritious parts of the
week
but most lowered his ground
to make whitewater
making quite plan or the week german
brand are removed
and the major portions of many minerals
inside a man's are lost
part of the protein and most of the
fiber are also lost
brannon outer layers are sold for cattle
and i will emerge
blue bread company makes quite bridge
they put back a few of the lawsuit
hand-held of some of the british
because it is in rich
okay jumps
seven ridge st contains only a few of
the original message
happily you don't have to buy white
most stores have a
variety of nutritious whole grain bread
supposed to be
fleets to fight by
if i can't fake anything else
but i thought we'd
we have a very good
he get at least read like this
getting more vitamins and more efficient
uh... white bread
many states don't even required in
richmond for some power crowd
nutritional loss from snacks pastries
and doughnuts maybe almost total
rice is another one of the range from
which we managed to remove most of the
nutritious elements
by taking off the outer layers
enriched quite rise has had several
vitamins and iron restored
but brown rice
whole grain rice that has not been
mailed
has all the original nutrients
the rights which advertisers urgency
is even less nutritious than white rice
after making instant prize
food companies who tend to make up for
the loss of nutrients
by dusting the grains with the vitamin
up
such highly processed foods are
increasingly replacing more nutritious
foods and i've died i'd like it might
look like
my colleague hamburger helper thing
right there were only an outback
larry when i get home from work what am
i gonna do it if cooked up five minute
becky everybody in that
created by fabricate spirit and stuff we
would like to fix up might think that it
in a long-running polly was alright
sapo doesn't
it goes over possible long-term
consequences to i don't think they have
more we are hang on to do
daily on bruce's foods and the less we
did that would supply debated by all the
voices foods that it would be for us
not only good for you but
fantastically delicious
you can be great to eat and that's the
thing about whole grains is that there
are always
not only much much better for you in
grains that are tampered with but
always without exception much more
delicious
we you know what was wrong
sodium content
sat over the
facility in sterile school lacked away
lacked the light
killian
tomorrow morning for a which arrives
cry potassium
prostrate
slowly along with the shift in the last
twenty years highly refined and
processed foods
there's been an enormous increase in the
use of food additives
a typical instant mashed potato package
s potatoes
but also these ingredients day
breakfast cake as trigger for water and
shortening
but also ca
a package salad dressing as all these
ingredients
xx
their diets
but first bleach is amal suppliers
preservatives flavors morse directions
and so forth
doesn't have a little bit earlier today
one reason companies like to use these
attitudes
is because it helps sales and profits
using preservatives mall suppliers and
stabilizers food manufacturers can
concoct completely new products like
putting caps
bheji mph thier added to potato chips
so packages can sit on the shelf for
three months without going straight
artificial flavors are used in ice cream
because they are much cheaper than
natural flavors
caramel coloring makes white bread
looked like whole wheat bread
egg bread is dyed yellow to make it look
rich in eggs
and a frozen breakfast drink imitates
real orange juice with the aid of an
orange dot
it's all imitation of the real work
right
and there's nothing
you know that's is versions of beautiful
finely is the real thing
there's controversy over the use of some
attitudes however
because they're potentially dangerous to
our help
it's not necessarily the case that
attitudes are always bear
that certainly isn't
but many attitude survey useful purposes
for instance the addition of vitamin
is is very useful
it getting high tax office has been very
useful in preventing
we have to be very careful about
attitudes
because the turns out that anyone
additive
very dangerous
that could mean higher
a tremendous number of people
and down through the years many
additives
and found to be dangerous
most of these is an artificial colors
so i think if there's any
any worry we should be worrying about
artificial colors
they've been found to cause allergic
reactions
and damage of several
uh... internal organs like liver and
heart
one controversy or who died that was
once widely used
is red number two
it was the most common of all food items
all of us consumed it
yet it has now been banned because it
was found to be dangerous to our help
other red does have been substituted for
it
hundreds of foods are colored with red
dot
the does make them look good
they help sales
a
it
boone
right
there are other evidence which are also
controversy
political opponents comic
in small print you'll find the words
sodium nitrite this is one of the
attitudes
to stay away from
sodium nitrite itself wasn't so great
problem arises
went sodium nitrite reacts with other
chemicals either in the
a radar summary
to create nitrosamines
tiny amounts of nitrosamines
have been found to cause cancer in
animals
food processors say sodium nitrite is
needed for tearing me
and to prevent botulism bacteria from
growing
off limits you simply to give meets a
bright pinkish color to increase their
sales appeal
many scientists and others think it
should be banned for this purpose
one place where it is definitely
unnecessary is invading
a few years ago another added mono
sodium gluconate m_s_g_
was widely used in baby foods
the purpose was to increase sales by
making the food more tasty to mothers
when doubts arose about the safety of
the mystery for babies
the manufacturers fought against
removing
eventually they were forced to
there was no need for to have been there
in the first place
each have a stake in an average of five
pounds of that it is a year
some clearly serve no legitimate need
and should be eliminated from our food
we need to be very carefully and i think
they've been dignity
indefinite multiplication
of any busy now put you brian we have
more than two thousand now
on the other end today in the morning
discriminatory act
it is that you be ignorant of the fact
that in some cases they increase rylan
decrease the safety of the food supply
still another change in our reading
habits as the high percentage of sugar
in our diet
by eating a lot of sugar we invite tooth
decay and other health problems
yet many of us have a sweet tooth and
food processors are happy to encourage
it
why don't they
keep out the email i promise you that
they have been in that because their
statements
secure again
hidden instead
had something terrible and tragic
accident and tomato crop
their father security and feel
incident this property is right kidney
have civilian week about a hundred and
and parking around
secured and year replace them
tonight since i'm not a shipping is
officially and beverages
a twelve ounce bottle of america's
favorite soft drink
has seven
nine teaspoons of sugar
americans are on the sugar drink bench
week annually consume more sugar drinks
than milk and fruit juices combined
peaches or do dessert
when they're packed in a heavy syrup you
get forty spoons of sugar per serving
in many cases we have substituted sugar
based products for more nutritious wants
artificially colored and flavored
breakfast ranks
have not only more sugar
but fewer vitamins and none of the
minerals that real fruit juices hair
ingredients in food are listed in order
by weight
if shivers first it means it's the
largest items
some breakfast cereals are almost fifty
percent
i like
contract yet
shantytowns
carey's here
i don't do this
they didn't report
we need to use headed to note
are likely to gamble
yeah i think if you could say that i'm
typing doing now
pressured rock break that you can
cabinet
can
hahha
very tasty
who can't laugh at satisfied because
like it can see that had sent a c
and if there's settlements that they get
the first debate
an intent to santa monica and i think
talk about
i've turned into a fight with supply and
trying to improve are provided
have come out of typing media
uh... kibuye these products frank
to again today saying its considerable
means about one and a half billion
dollars on media about
three billion dollars both though
packets is a very different function
from advertising in general
acting general advertising actin stupid
increase consumption a certain goods and
then shift preference to seven brands
in the case of food however the total
amount of full would you believe these
independent of the amount of advertising
you see
all of the pacing does these shifts
your food supply for you putting take
from one type of food to another
we can bring consumes in four different
groups with nutrition declining from
group to group
and the first group would be
vegetables fruits eggs milk cheese meat
and hope we products
and the second
white bread potatoes macaroni products
some of the better breakfast cereals
and soups
and the third
and now a nutritional value is going
down rapidly
suru coated breakfast cereals some snack
foods
cake mixes and so forth
and in the fourth
soft drinks and many snack foods
however if we hate these foods in
proportion to the advertising given to
them
this is how much we might need from each
group uh...
we're
within their big break down of the event
that is in really the issue
tried to shift the food preferences of
americans
from the better foolish to the worst
foods and i'm afraid very successful at
the all the date that we have on the
nutrient consumption by the american
people to show that since
nineteen fifty-five there's been a
really beat deregulation
eating the food supply yes consumed and
i think that the banking very
responsible
we have a choice
we can eat the factory foods that are
pushed on this by advertising
or we can save money any better with
more unprocessed natural foods
there
yell
aravind crowd